everyone makes mistakes and that
includes everyone who employs an army of
agents managers and publicists just to
avoid those mistakes but when you're an
a-list actor your slip-ups are captured
on film projected six stories high and
immortalized for criticism all it takes
is one box-office bomb to blow up a
star's reputation here are some actors
whose careers were ruined by just one
role Sean Connery in the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen the original
James Bond Sean Connery repositioned
himself in the 90s as a first ATOL
action hero with The Hunt for Red
October and the rock and he even grabbed
the title of People's Sexiest man of the
century at age 69 in 2003 he returned as
executive producer and star of the
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
adapted from the popular graphic novel
series I'm waiting to be impressed the
movie was a box-office flop and a
critical bond both shaken and stirred
Connery hasn't appeared in a movie since
officially announcing his retirement in
2005 Halle Berry in Catwoman after her
oscar-winning performance in 2001 s
monsters bull Halle Berry could have had
any role she wanted unfortunately what
she wanted was Catwoman the 2004 Batman
kind of spin-off nearly swept the
Razzies and Barry took most of the
fallout was the Arizona Republic even
suggesting she returned her Academy
Award
instead Barry returned to a diminishing
role a storm in the x-men film series
and has all but disappeared from leading
roles Cuba Gooding jr. in boat trip Cuba
Gooding jr. rose to fame in 1991 as a
lead in boys in the hood a movie so
important that it's in the National Film
registry he went on to win an Oscar for
his work in Jerry Maguire and continued
rolling with as good as it gets what
dreams may come and Men of Honor in 2002
however he unleashed his first 2
starring vehicles the family comedy snow
dogs and the offensively horrible comedy
boat trips sex that's all you ever think
about sex sex sex
we'll take both for critical disasters
but at least snow dogs made money with
his credibility blown pudding only made
things worse with later Razzie nominated
roles in radio Norbit and daddy day
count what could possibly go wrong
of the 18 movies he released between
2008 and 2013 all but 5 went straight to
DVD Neve Campbell in wild things Neve
Campbell was inescapable in the late
nineties almost single-handedly sparking
the nineties horror revival with scream
and scream - earning herself two
consecutive Best Female performance wins
at the MTV Movie Awards the cover of
Rolling Stone and an SNL hosting gig but
Campbell shed her good dell image and
most of her clothes for the embarrassing
erotic thriller wild things her career
never recovered
Campbell clung to the Scream franchise
for two more sequels in 2000 and 2011
but otherwise toiled on studio clunkers
like three to tango and secondary indie
flix like when will I be loved she
resurfaced in 2016 for a part on house
of cards
maybe that will finally get her back on
track Topher Grace in spider-man 3 from
critically acclaimed performances in
Steven Soderbergh's traffic and PS 2
starring roles in win a date with Ted
Hamilton and in good company
former That 70's Show star Topher Grace
seemed poised for full-time movie
stardom then he signed on to play venom
in Sam Raimi's overwrought spider-man 3
oh my spider sense is tingling
if you know what I'm talking about
although the movie was still a
blockbuster graces performance was
loathed by fans he still found roles in
predators and interstellar but
spider-man 3 diminished Grace's
viability as a leading man still at
least he wasn't the worst thing about
the movie King Costner in Waterworld at
one point Kevin Costner was one of the
biggest movie stars in the world he put
together a string of huge successes
including Field of Dreams The
Untouchables Bull Durham the bodyguard
and Dances with Wolves which earned him
two Oscars he could seemingly do no
wrong but when cosna put his clout
behind the high concept dystopian action
flick Waterworld he ended up in over his
head
the notorious production nightmare that
barely made any money due to its
engorged budget it also took a critical
flogging now since then it's been hit or
miss at best for Costner he still turns
in strong performances in small dramas
like 13 days and open range and
occasionally appears in supporting roles
in blockbusters like Man of Steel but
his own days as a top-tier leading man
seem to have sunk to the bottom forever
with Waterworld thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]